THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS FINALIZING
PLANS TO SEND PATRIOT MISSILES,
ITS MOST ADVANCED AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEM, TO HELP KYIV COUNTER
MOSCOW'S RELENTLESS MISSILE
ATTACKS WHICH HAVE POUNDED
UKRAINE'S POWER GRID AND OTHER
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE RUSSIAN EMBASSY IN
WASHINGTON SAYS THAT SENDING
THE PATRIOTS WOULD LEAD TO
UNPREDICTABLE CONSEQUENCES.
JOINING ME NOW FROM KYIV TO
ASSESS WHERE A COLD WINTER OR
PUT THE, IS UKRAINE'S FOREIGN
MINISTER TO BE TRUE COOLLY OF.
PRIME MINISTER, WELCOME BACK TO
THE PROGRAM.
CAN I START BY ASKING YOU,
WHERE DO YOU THINK AND HOW SOON
DO YOU THINK YOU WILL GET THE
PATRIOTS?
AND HOW MUCH OF A DIFFERENCE IT
WILL MAKE TO THE WAR EFFORT?
>> IT IS NOT FOR ME TO DISCLOSE
WHAT THE FINAL DECISION OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL BE.
BUT I CAN REITERATE THAT WE
HAVE DONE A LOT IN COOPERATION
WITH OUR AMERICAN PARTNERS.
TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE AND
PARTICULARLY THE LAST
CONVERSATION BETWEEN OUR
PRESIDENTS, PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
ZELENSKYY, WAS VERY PATRIOTIC.
OF COURSE, THIS SYSTEM IS
CERTAINLY PROVIDED TO UKRAINE.
THEY WILL BE A GAME-CHANGER IN
THE PROTECTION OF UKRAINIAN
CITIES AND CIVILIANS AND CIVIL
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> YOU HAVE NO DOUBT HEARD THAT
THE RUSSIAN EMBASSY HAS SAID IT
COULD LEAD TO UNPREDICTABLE
CONSEQUENCES.
THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTRY
SPOKESPERSON HAS SAID THAT THIS
WOULD MEAN BRINGING THE U.S.
MORE CLOSELY INTO DIRECT
INVOLVEMENT IN THE UKRAINIAN
CONFLICT.
DO THOSE WORDS RATTLE YOU?
>> EMPTY WORDS.
WE HEARD THESE THREATENING
COMMENTS SO MANY TIMES BEFORE.
AND THEY NEVER PROVED TO BE A
REALITY.
RUSSIA HAS ALREADY CROSSED ALL
THE RED LINES AND THEY HAVE NOT
SPARED ANYONE.
NEITHER ANIMALS NOR NATURE NOR
CIVILIANS NOR CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY DESTROYED EVERYTHING.
SO THEY BURY SPOTS ABILITY FOR
THAT.
OF COURSE, THEY WANT US TO BE
WEAK AND THAT IS WHY THEY SPEAK
AGAINST ANY DELIVERY OF WEAPONS,
BUT THE REALITY IS DIFFERENT
AND WE WILL BE GETTING
STRONGER.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR
STRENGTH.
THIS WHOLE FORM SEASON OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS HAS BEEN
MARKED BY A HUGE AMOUNT OF
COUNTEROFFENSIVES BY YOUR
FORCES, AND REGAINING
TERRITORY.
AT THE SAME TIME, RUSSIA HAS
THIS HUGE MOBILIZATION AND YOUR
PRESIDENT AND THE GENERALS HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT CONCERNS FOR
THE FUTURE, POTENTIALLY THAT
RUSSIA WILL REGROUP.
IT HAS A LOT MORE PEOPLE.
AND IT MIGHT BE READY FOR
ANOTHER MAJOR OFFENSIVE
SOMETIME EARLY IN THE NEW YEAR.
>> THAT IS WHY WE HAVE TO BE
READY FOR OUR COUNTEROFFENSIVES
AND OUR EFFORTS TO STOP THE
POTENTIAL RUSSIAN OFFENSIVE.
AND THIS IS WHY IT IS IMPORTANT
TO CONTINUE SUPPLYING UKRAINE
WITH HOWITZERS AND AMMUNITION
AND OTHER ADVANCED WEAPONS.
THIS IS A WAR AND OF COURSE
BOTH SIDES HAVE THEIR OWN
PLANS.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ATHLETES
AND RUSSIA IS THAT WE ARE
FIGHTING A JUST WAR DEFENDING
OURSELVES AND THEREFORE WE HAVE
FULL RIGHT UNLIMITED BY ANY WAR,
TO RECEIVE EVERYTHING THAT WE
NEED TO DEFEAT RUSSIA.
AND THIS IS WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN, EVENTUALLY.
>> EVENTUALLY.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE BATTLEFIELD
SHAPING UP IN 2023?
AND I ALSO WANT TO ASK YOU
WHETHER YOU SEE A DIFFERENCE IN
TACTIC, AT LEAST, IF NOT
STRATEGY, SINCE PRESIDENT PUTIN
NAMED --
AS THE BATTLEFIELD COMMANDER.
WE OBVIOUSLY SEE THE TACTICS
THAT THEY USED IN CHECHNYA, IN
SYRIA, BEING USED AGAINST YOUR
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
POUNDING CIVILIANS.
POUNDING EVEN PLACES LIKE HORSE,
ON WHICH HAVE BEEN LIBERATED.
JUST TRYING TO BREAK YOUR,
SPIRIT BREAK THE SPIRIT OF THE,
PEOPLE AND TURN THIS COUNTRY
INTO RUBBLE.
>> THE APPOINTMENT OF THE NEW
COMMANDER ON THE RUSSIAN SIDE
MADE THE WAR EVEN MORE RUTHLESS.
NOT ONLY WERE THEIR GUARDS TO
UKRAINIANS WHOM THE RUSSIANS
ARE FIGHTING BUT ALSO WITH
REGARDS TO THE RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
THEMSELVES.
WE SEE THAT RUSSIAN MAN THROWN
INTO THE BATTLE ARE USED BY
THEIR GENERALS CAN INVOLVE.
THEY'RE AND THEY HAVE NO MERCY
TOWARDS THEM WHATSOEVER.
OUR STRATEGY IS VERY SIMPLE.
TO PREVENT A RUSSIAN OFFENSIVE
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THEM BUSY WITH
COUNTERING ARE OFFENSIVE.
OUR --
OFFENSIVE AND WE SHOULD NOT
ALLOW RUSSIA TO DICTATE THE
SITUATION ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
AND TO DO THAT WE NEED MORE
HEAVY WEAPONS.
AS I SAID HOWITZERS, TANKS,
LOTS OF AMMUNITIONS AND LAUNCH
ROCKET SYSTEMS.
WE SHOULD CHANGE THE OPTICS.
HELP UKRAINE NOT TO DEFEND
ITSELF, HELP UKRAINE TO
LIBERATE ITS TERRITORIES AND TO
WIN THIS WAR.
THE SOONER IT ENDS WITH UKRAINE
'S VICTORY THE BETTER WILL BE
FOR ALL.
>> TO THAT AND YOU HAVE
OBVIOUSLY HEARD AND YOU HAVE
ALL REPORTED ON THESE RAISING
OF THE VIEW THAT THERE MIGHT BE
SOME KIND OF NEGOTIATION
POSSIBLE OR PRESSURED AND
THAT'S CLEARLY YOUR SIDE HAS
SAID THAT WE ARE NOT READY TO
DO THAT.
BUT PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY CALLED
FOR RUSSIAN FORCES TO START
WITHDRAWING BY THIS CHRISTMAS.
THEY HAVE SAID THAT THAT IS A
NON STARTER AND THEY ARE ONLY
TALKING IF PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
AGREES TO THEY ARE MAXIMALIST
DEMANDS, WHICH ARE TO ACCEPT
ALL THIS OCCUPIED TERRITORY.
WHERE IN YOUR MIND IS THERE ANY
SPACE AT THE MOMENT FOR ANY
KIND OF NEGOTIATION?
>> PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY PROPOSED
A VERY REASONABLE AND PEACEFUL
CONCEIT OF TEN ELEMENTS.
NEGOTIATIONS AND FIXING THE END
OF THE WAR ON THE PAPER IS STEP
TEN NOT STEP ONE.
THIS PROCESS OF ENDING THE WAR
SHOULD BEGIN WITH THE
WITHDRAWAL OF RUSSIAN FORCES.
AND THERE ARE MANY OTHER ISSUES
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN
THIS CONTEXT.
SO NO ONE SHOULD BE BUYING THE
RUSSIAN SMOKESCREEN OPERATION,
WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENTS DOING NEGOTIATIONS
WITH ONE HAND, AND PUSH THE
BUTTON SENDING MORE MISSILES,
MORE DRONES, AND MORE RUSSIAN
TROOPS AGAINST UKRAINE WITH THE
OTHER HAND.
FOR RUSSIA, AS I SAID, TALKS IS
JUST A SMOKESCREEN.
WE CANNOT SEE ANYTHING OF
INDICATOR THAT WE ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT THEM.
>> WE ARE WATCHING THE ATTACKS
ON YOUR ENERGY SYSTEM AND WE
KNOW PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN
FREEZING CONDITIONS.
UNICEF HAS SAID POTENTIALLY ONE
AND A HALF MILLION CHILDREN
COULD SUFFER DEPRESSION,
ANXIETY, AND OTHER CONDITIONS.
AS WELL AS MANY WHO ARE HERE TO
BE A MORTAL RISK THIS WINTER.
DO YOU THINK YOU HAVE THE
SITUATION UNDER CONTROL TO
SURVIVE THE WINTER?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, ANYTIME
THERE IS AN AIR RAID SIREN IN
KYIV, THE FIRST THING I DO IS
CALL IN MY CHILDREN TO HELP,
THEM TO COPE WITH THE ANXIETY.
AND FEAR.
ABOUT ANOTHER RUSSIAN ATTACK.
EVERY TIME IT IS, OVER I SPEAK
WITH THEM AGAIN AND WE DISCUSS
IT.
SO I HELPED THEM TO COPE WITH
I PERFECTLY KNOW WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
BUT, YES WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
FACING A RUTHLESS ENEMY WHO IS
DESTROYING EVERYTHING, TRYING
TO BREAK US DOWN.
BUT THIS MOVING IN UKRAINE IS,
EVEN AT THE MOST DIFFICULT,
PLACES THE SAME.
PUTIN IS NOT GOING TO BREAK US
DOWN.
WHATEVER IT TAKES, DOESN'T
MATTER HOW DIFFICULT IT WILL BE,
WE WILL SURVIVE AND WE WILL
SURVIVE THIS WINTER AGAINST ALL
ODDS.
THIS IS THE MOOD BOTH OUTSIDE
OF KYIV, OUTSIDE OF THE
BUILDING, OR ON THE STREETS OF
KYIV AND ALSO ON THE FRONT
LINE.